hey kids walk back to new rockstars I'm
Sam Bosch and I'm here today to remind
you that we're about to get the most
epic superhero movie of all time in
theaters this year that's right ant-man
and the wasps no it's Avengers infinity
war got you dumb little joke to start
2018 you're very welcome
don't worry Avengers infinity war won't
be hitting theatres May 28 teen very
exciting dear Lord we're gonna allow
superhero movies this year and if you
want to know the entire list of them you
can go and check out my video I did on
this channel
alright here but anyhow this year we're
gonna be seeing most if not all of our
current Avengers and MCU supporting cast
team mates coming together to take on
the mad Titan himself Thanos the villain
with a chin for days most of us have
been keeping up with most of the news
about this film you're aware that Thanos
and his children the Black Order will be
searching the cosmos for all six of the
Infinity stones in the MCU to bring them
together to complete the Infinity with
this Thanos can wreak all kinds of havoc
on the universe and beyond but let's not
get into spoiler territory just yet
we'll save that for another video but
today I wanna get you all up to speed on
the current whereabouts and histories of
the Infinity stones in the MCU and what
we could expect from them power wise and
infinity war now of course like most of
our videos here is your spoiler warning
for what I don't know it like you
clicked on the video so there's gonna be
spoilers let's say the infinity war
movie Infinity Gauntlet storyline in the
comics anytime they popped up in the
comics all MCU movies TV shows etc etc
spoilers from here to the end of time
also spoilers for this one time I was a
background dancer in a music video
[Music]
you're welcome let's get started let's
kick this off with what are the Infinity
stones well in guardians the galaxy
volume 1 we hear the collectors say this
yes for creation itself there were 16
gravity then the universe exploded into
existence and the remnants of these
systems were forged into concentrated
ingots is quite taking that and applying
it to the comic book explanation of the
infinity gems which is their comic
accurate name but before that they were
soul gems and infinity gems and now
Infinity stones anyways with all that
we're able to understand that these are
aspects of our universe expressed as
these stones make sense hey whatever and
those elements of our universe our
space-time soul mind power and reality
sure if you were to break down what
makes up a universe in the real world
this list would be a little bit
different but hey comic books actually
the most recent guardians the galaxy
comic which I recommend you reading they
describe our universe as a simulation
and the stones as the source code of
said simulation pretty cool and explains
if someone were to get their hands on
the source code of the universe they
could do some serious damage like if
someone had their hands on the time
stone they could possibly rewrite all of
time in an instant or if they had the
space stone they could just rip a hole
the fabric of the universe and
everything could just plunge into
nothingness being that these are the
embodiment of these pieces of the
university stones are extremely powerful
when wielded by a living being which
we've seen expressed in the films
although not all living beings you got
to have some extra power if you want to
play with that kind of fire usually they
can only be controlled by someone or
something of immense power themselves
but not always the case like how we see
dr. strange utilizing the time stone
when sits you know house in the eye of
agamotto well when Loki uses the mind
stone when it's inside of his sceptre to
control Hawkeye so big the list goes on
and on now let's talk about the fun
stuff what each individual stone is
capable of and maybe some abilities we
haven't seen just yet on the big screen
first up let's talk about the first
stone we were introduced to this base
stone which is currently inside the
tesseract so far we see them the stone
used to create weapons for Hydra during
world war ii these weapons seemed to
vaporize anyone who came in contact with
the projectiles a little blast but it
wasn't till the Red Skull grabbed the
tesseract with his bare hand did we see
the real power of this stone he just
shot right up into space just right up
in there he's probably
dad maybe maybe the current theory state
that the red skull was killed at this
moment or possibly he's alive somewhere
in the infinity that is space or
possibly he maybe is in multiple places
at once I'll get back to that in just a
second will later see the space stone
live up to its name by literally ripping
a hole in space for the evading Chitauri
army to fly through and attack New York
City in the Avengers film thankfully the
Avengers were able to stop this in time
and close the portal but this is still
just a fraction of its power when
utilized correctly the space stone can
allow the user to be omnipresent or
everywhere in the universe at once when
used in other ways they could you know
teleport anywhere in the universe they
like replicates SuperSpeed who objects
or beings anywhere the user chooses or
literally change the distance of two
points by warping space pretty cool does
that mean that the red school is split
up and living in multiple places in the
universe at the same time did he
teleport somewhere else or are you just
super dead his organs are just spread
out to the stars there's a lot of
options let me know your theories in the
comments down below also worth
mentioning it's usually the purple stone
in the comics but in the movies it's
blue I'm okay with that next we meet the
ether I'm skipping the mind stone for
just a second but we'll come back to it
okay don't worry the ether again from
what we're able to gather is the MCU
version of the reality stone in the
comics I'm being kind of vague because
we haven't really seen the ether using
the way that resembles the reality stone
in the comics but I'm getting ahead of
myself while normally yellow in the
comics is red material in the films has
been used as a weapon that was told to
be able to revert the universe or
reality back to a darker age pre-big
bang by turning matter into dark matter
wow that does sound evil it doesn't
really sound like the reality gem that
we know and love although it's not
usually like flying goop but I enjoyed
the effect in Thor 2 like that movie too
much but that was fine when used
properly though it's basically a wishing
stone it can make anything in reality
possible or impossible
you could will something into being even
if it doesn't obey the laws of physics
hell you could throw out the laws of
physics and make new ones and make a
whole new universe if you'd like now
what we see this in infinity war I kind
of hope so but how could the hole-punch
reality back together see we all got
heavy hitters we don't need more agents
we need more cosmic level beings so I
have no idea but now moving on to the
next infinity stone that's got
it's own movie it was the power stone or
the orb that we saw as the MacGuffin in
guardians the galaxy vol 1
for the most part besides the comic
power gem being red not purple the Power
Stone in the film is fairly accurate to
the comics fairly basically can be used
to enhance the user strength durability
etc and give the user omnipotence when
the full power of the stone is accessed
but here's the kicker when combined with
the other Infinity stones it can boost
all of their power making it far scarier
now that's pretty cool but let's talk
about our next stone because I've very
intrigued to see how it will be used in
infinity war I'm talking about the mind
stone the stone to star in both Avengers
films well usually it's blue in the
comics like it was in the first Avengers
film this yellow stone is both the cause
of Ultron going crazy and murderous but
also the power that brought the vision
to life and gave him his powers who
knows fair enough it's crazy space rocks
it can do whatever it wants as for all
of its capabilities however we've seen
it take control of the minds of Hawkeye
so big dr. Helen Cho and others as well
as bestow knowledge and wisdom who
Ultron envisioned but when its power is
fully unleashed this baby can connect
with every single mind in existence at
once that could allow the user to take
control of any brain they would like but
also access all of their thoughts
memories and more they can even enhance
certain psychics abilities as well so if
this Fox Disney deal could move a little
bit faster just a little bit faster we
could see Professor X wielding a mine
stone not the worst idea in the world
would be pretty cool the next stone on
our list made its debut in Doctor
Strange switching its color from orange
to green please welcome the time stone
to the stage you guys get the idea this
one allows the user to manipulate time
maybe just the time of specific objects
like here or maybe all of time maybe
even creating a time loop in certain
instances but at full power this stone
can allow the user full access to the
past present future and everything in
between and complete control over all
time these are just getting scarier and
scarier by the minute aren't they well
don't worry because the last stone on
the list is just a little small one if
the soul stone it's the only one we
haven't seen yet the MCU as far as we
know this one it can't be a scary right
it's a little green gem in the comics
but it's probably gonna be orange and
the movies most likely except for again
take control of all living and dead
souls if you want it to it can corrupt
them
basically have control over all life in
the universe it might be the most
terrifying one but good news it can also
act as a gateway to a little pocket
dimension where Souls can live like a
little heaven that's pretty fun if you
ask me so there you go that's what the
Avengers and the guardians of the galaxy
are up against in infinity war sure they
did a pretty good job at fighting off a
few of these stones one at a time barely
but all together that's gotta be a
pretty scary scenario I'm very excited
to see them on the big screen but really
quick let's talk about where these
stones are now and where they have been
where did they come from also if you are
an awesome visual history of the MCU
which I recommend you check out our
friend Erik and new rock stars put
together this awesome video click it
check it out anyways pre-big bang these
stones were systems floating around in
the cosmos and then were concentrated in
two stones after the explosion creating
our universe following that we gather
the Celestials like s on the searcher
that we saw in guardians vol 1 use the
power stone and possibly more stones to
pass judgment on whole civilizations
wiping out entire planets if they so
choose in just a few seconds Oh No
that's scary following that we see the
ether aka the reality stone floating
around doing its thing Malekith the dark
elf the guy we saw in Thor 2 was
planning to use this to revert all nine
realms back to pre Big Bang darkness but
was thwarted by the Asgardians and bore
and the ether was stored away for
safekeeping somewhere that nobody knew
anyways this is far in the past let's
get forward 5000 years to world war 2 we
have the Red Skull and his men
discovering the hidden tesseract slash
space stone but anyways you guys know
the story Red Skull gets booted into
space and the tesseract falls in the
Atlantic Ocean to be recovered by Howard
Stark Tony Stark's dead be and shield
and we don't see that again until the
Avengers film during the Battle of New
York we see the power of the space stone
with the destruction of project Pegasus
out in the desert in the portal over New
York this film is also the introduction
to the mine stone that was hidden inside
of Loki's scepter which was definitely
in Vanessa's possession and he totally
lost it he already had a gem of stone if
you will that must have been a bummer
after the battle the space stone along
with Loki are transported back to Asgard
for safekeeping
then skip forward to the second time
Malekith decided to try to destroy the
universe with the newly discovered ether
during this convergence event in Thor 2
and all the rain
wormholes opening up Jane Foster
actually gets sucked into one and she
pops up in the hiding spot where the
ether is and it all gets sucked inside
of her body eventually Malekith gets his
hands on her sucks it out of her Thor
stop Sam thor kills Malekith and as
Guardians decide to hide the ether on
nowhere with the collector makes sense
you don't want to keep two Infinity
stones in the same place boy are they
gonna be surprised about how many are
hidden on earth then scooting forward to
Guardians Volume one we discover that at
some point between the Celestials using
the Power Stone just after the Big Bang
until 2014 the power stone was hidden
away in an orb on the planet Morag the
Ravagers and yondu get word of this but
Peter quill steals that Intel runs the
morgue before they can get there just in
time to steal it right ass our favorite
Thanos goons show up Ronan the accuser
and his pals you know the story of Ronan
gets the stone threatens the kills and
are the Guardians stopped him the stone
is safely stored by the Nova Corps in a
vault ons and are huge in back doors we
find out that Hydra got their hands on
Loki's staff following the first
Avengers movie and they've been using
the mine stone to unlock abilities in
certain individuals specifically
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch eventually
that stone is used to make Ultron then
he used to make vision to stop Ultron
and now resides in divisions forehead to
make laser beams and make him fly and
walk through walls you know rain powers
I know fans of vision will explain his
abilities in the comments I've looked up
on it but just from the point of view
the movies it doesn't quite make sense
next up we discover that the sorcerers
and magic folk of Earth had been
safeguarding the time stone for quite
some time
hidden safely within the eye of agamotto
Doctor Strange is able to use it to
defeat Dormammu hi Silius and return the
world back to working order after the
conflict he returns the eye and the time
stone back onto its little pedestal for
safekeeping BAM that's it so far we
thought we'd finally find the location
of the soul stone in Ragnarok seeing as
how Hellas they got us a death and it
makes sense that she'd used this stone
to feed off people's souls and power
when she killed them but all we got was
a tease of Loki possibly taking the
tesseract from Asgard record exploded
and that's it being confirmed in the
infinity war trailer when he hands it
over to Thanos or one of his Black Order
that's it though we don't know what the
soul stone is or do we before we get to
that though let's do a quick rundown
space stone it's on that Asgardian
getaway ship mine stone it's in
divisions pink for head time stone it's
inside that eye on the shelf power
stones inside a vault on an alien world
the ether aka the reality stone is in
nowhere sure the collectors home kind of
exploded during guardians volume 1 but
I'm sure that probably didn't destroy
infinity stone am i right am i right on
that right
the last question we're left with is
where's the soul stone while kids got
three theories one Thanos already has it
and we just don't know it as far as the
stones we saw in the trailer we can
confirm that he gets the space and power
stones within this movie but we can't
see his thumb which does hold the stone
and based on the teaser we saw a couple
of years ago for infinity war and it
looks like a perfect place to store an
orange one aka the soul stone ensuring
you could point out that all the colors
of the stones and that teaser don't line
up with the trailer that we just got but
there's a chance the soul stone could
already be on a stump since we can't see
it in that chart where he's dropping the
stones into place it's an option that's
all I'm saying
but here's theory - what if we don't see
it in the Avengers infinity war there's
a chance that as a way to hold off
between the 3rd Avengers film and
Avengers 4 the Avengers are able to hide
the soul stone from Thanos before he's
able to get to it maybe they send it off
world well maybe to another dimension
thanks to dr. strange so this might
explain the two separate Avengers films
or at least have some story to connect
them again this is just an option but
theory 3 is my personal favorite I'm
thinking that Wakanda is secretly
holding on to a soul stone this is a
pretty popular theory on the internet
right now and it would explain why there
is such a huge fight outside of Rwanda
in the infinity war trailer most likely
but Conda has been using the soul stone
as a way to communicate there's also
called the king of the Dead I think we
actually see a hint of the previously
mentioned pockets old dimension in the
Black Panther trailer remember that clip
where T'Challa is walking into a field
with purple sky and there's a bunch of
Panthers sitting on a tree their eyes
are glowing feeling like he's communing
with the spirits of previous Black
Panthers in a realm of the Dead maybe
that's what kill monger wants to use to
take control of the world it does make
sense he'd be very effective you take
control of every single living thing on
a planet hoo boy that's scary but what
do you guys think this is going to be
one of the most epic movies to date and
I can't wait to see what they do with
the Infinity stones
let me know your thoughts and theories
on the soul stones whereabouts and
infinity war in general in the comments
down below but before you do that give
this video a like check out our full MCU
timeline video is two very good and
subscribe the new rock stars for more
content also make sure you tune in at
the end of the week for our panel show
it's very fun I think you guys will
enjoy
I'm Sam bash on Twitter some of your MCU
theories I'd love to hear
I'll see you guys next time